now let's imagine for a moment that a
christian university let's say in rural
texas
has a lab that's doing research on
viruses as part of their work on future
vaccines
now the work involves making the viruses
they're studying more pathogenic
then a novel coronavirus appears in that
same town as the university lab
and then ends up killing some people and
then it starts spreading around the
world
the scientists at the university insist
that their work had nothing to do with
this new coronavirus
they also refused to cooperate with any
health agency
other than those controlled by the state
of texas
the republican governor of texas in this
hypothetical is backing the university
now how would the regime press cover
that story
and do you think the biden
administration would be demanding
answers
issuing condemnations of these risky
practices
and citing the crushing loss of life and
gargantuan economic consequences
caused by this irresponsible university
well of course it would and of course
the left would just assume that the lab
leak was purposeful at that university
yeah let's get back to real life
biden's team lets china off the hook
completely for what it did in wuhan for
the ensuing cover-up and for the
cataclysmic harm it inflicted on our
country
now going back to february 2020 before
the pandemic was
even declared
i knew something was up when i asked
anthony fauci directly about china's
response to the outbreak
the chinese authorities have really been
very explicit
that they were going to not tolerate any
misinformation i'm surprised that you
would say that given what we know about
china's pattern of lying about critical
issues dr fauci the chinese scientist
we've dealt with i've dealt with myself
personally for years if not decades many
of them have trained here in the united
states i have faith that they are not
distorting things
so revealing
now fast forward to this week at the u.n
despite all the challenges with trade
human rights and the virus both biden
and harris went out of their way
not to single out china
but if we don't hold china accountable
how the heck can we prevent this from
happening again and again and again
but don't worry because our vice
president wants to throw money at some
global health slush fund
of some billion dollar total
to avoid the mistakes of the past and
meet this present moment we must also
ensure
transparency and accountability
to ensure that all countries
meet our global health obligations a
global health threats council that would
monitor progress and identify gaps
identify gaps
if china is lying and hiding facts
we won't even know where to look
now the press is more obsessed with
covering a riot where one unarmed
protester was killed then a pandemic
that killed more than 675
000 americans
the fact is china is howling at us
they're laughing they got away with
global death and destruction and
america's response is the equivalent of
thank you sir i have another
the order of how things went down with
biden and china goes something like this
now early on in the administration team
biden thought that europe would help us
put pressure on china to change its ways
but of course with trump gone europe is
cutting its own deals with china and
stiff-arm does basically
then blinking was embarrassed by china
in alaska
so we now have john kerry essentially
running our china policy
that fact should terrify every living
american
the man has been underestimating and
mishandling our relationship with china
for decades
our nations have worked together to
bring about important progress on a
range of global issues
including
a landmark agreement on climate change
in paris last year we also
worked very closely together
on the joint comprehensive plan of
action on iran's nuclear program there
is no us strategy
to try to push back against or be in
conflict with china
now remember when kerry visited china
earlier this month senior officials
in china
wouldn't even dignify him with a meeting
in person only over zoom he went all the
way over there
they sent a junior level staffer to
deliver their demands to carrie
how insulting
well he took that lesson to heart and
returned from that utterly embarrassing
trip at an even bigger see as as an even
bigger ccp apologist than he was before
there are other things as well such as
the uyghur situation in the west uh what
what is the process by which one trades
off climate against human rights well
life you know
life is always full of tough choices in
in the relationship between nations
now the choice of standing up for human
rights
is perhaps tough for kerry because of
the incredible financial leverage the
ccp has over his family
just yesterday we learned that john
kerry's wife teresa hines is heavily
invested in china through her family
trust
government ethics disclosures reveal
carrie's wife has over a million dollar
interest in a new york-based investment
firm that is run by a chinese citizen
and has major holdings in chinese
companies
now
how does
this add up to someone being at least
having an appearance of a conflict of
interest if not an actual one
but the biden administration just
doesn't care here
conflicts of interest corruption that's
it is part and parcel of the biden
family tradition
and carrie's family has played a
supportive role all along
back in 2009 kerry's stepson christopher
hines
teamed up with none other than hunter
biden to found a private equity firm
that went on to enter lucrative
partnerships with ccp owned companies
and they also got a multi-million dollar
deal with the chinese oil giant cfec
now heinz's attorney swears he played no
role in any of these ventures
okay but we know the biden family
absolutely did
and i'm not just talking about hunter
i want to remind you
and think about this may 2017 email that
was recovered from hunter's laptop by
the new york post last year
in the message one of hunter's partners
mentioned setting aside a chunk of
equity
in their china deal for the quote big
guy
well it's obvious who that was
on may 13 2017 i received an email
concerning allocation of equity
which says 10 percent held by h for the
big guy
in that email there's no question that h
stands for hunter
big guy for his father
joe biden
the financial entanglements between the
biden administration and the ccp are
real and they're frightening
and they cast some of the more
inexplicable decisions that our
government has recently made
in a new and perhaps more understandable
light
now consider the shocking news that the
secret service in fbi
just purchased surveillance drones
from a chinese company that the pentagon
itself had just singled out as a
potential security risk
how the heck was that allowed to happen
if biden really wants to save our global
position
and save taiwan boost our manufacturers
put china back on its heels
at this point he has a simple to-do list
if he wants to do any of that number one
he should just leave all of trump's
trade policies in place they worked
number two stop relying on europe focus
on the china threat
with or without them
and number three
fire john kerry
well is biden going to do any of this
probably not i'm not holding my breath
president xi is treating us like at this
point just a play thing it's almost
pathetic it's so easy to play the united
states
he knows that with biden and carrie at
the helm well he's got this in the bag
because sleepy joe is already bought and
paid for
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else